[Musique]
et les gens là qui passent leur temps à
relever les fautes d'orthographe la
croyais pas que vous allez au paradis
mais vous n'êtes pas des bonnes
personnes il y a une salle pour vous en
enfer ou toute la journée vous faites
des dictées vais vous la raconter
normalement il est là il arrive dans pas
longtemps à regarder la rive
allez c'est parti
où est-ce qu'il y a avec ma
belle-famille le gars il comprend pas le
français du coup je peux dire des trucs
un peu chaud ça passe crème
ça te dit on fait l'amour
mamie
6 ans
[Musique]
c'est un enfant
de la part de toute la nation française
présente
donne tout calculé les artistes parce
que on fait du bien aux gens qui nous
font du bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]